Chris let me start with a the NC
double-a tournament here we've talked
about some of the NBA talent the Alonso
ball marquel folds Tatum at Duke if you
were going to give us maybe your top
five top ten to keep an eye on who will
be playing first-round picks next year
give us some other names as well yeah I
mean when you get past you know those
surefire top five guys and you know
there might be some maneuvering in that
top five but not much most of the NBA
people I talk to our kind of locked in
those mid to late first-round picks I'll
throw a couple of names at you Dan
Justin patent over at Creighton is
generating a lot of interest he's a
7-footer who's got those kind of guard
skills came really out of nowhere this
year lightly recruited out of high
school he redshirted his freshman season
scouts I've talked you want to see him
play against Oregon maybe even
Louisville later on so there's one Harry
Giles at Duke I mean the focus is on
tatum of course but no Giles has been
kind of a major disappointment for much
of this season he started to show
flashes in that ACC tournament he has a
chance to rebound from a guide that you
know really started off this season as
almost a surefire lottery pick and now
he's kind of in the 20s he can really
improve his draft stock with the strong
tournament another name that comes up a
lot is Jonathan motley how did bail a
ton of skill all the physical tools you
can dream up you'll do really well at
the combine the testing but he's sloppy
is a rebound particularly well if baylor
wins a few games he's going to have a
great chance to improve his stock right
Alonzo ball story you know I mentioned
that the most popular name going into
the tournament is actually the dad of a
popular player but it is is that helping
or hurting or is there any impact on his
dad and what could happen once he gets
into the NBA or starts negotiating with
the team his dads having zero impact
whatsoever I've asked this question some
multiple executives that I've even
talked to our own front office insider
with the vertical Bobby marks it was of
course my assistant GM in Brooklyn and
you know they all say it's not an issue
whatsoever I mean there's no indication
that the dad is having a negative effect
on the Sun the dad just seems to like to
say so
and Lonzo seems to kind of go along with
the flow now I'm sure he could give
executives headaches down the line if he
starts publicly complaining about
playing time or position I'm telling you
then the dream for me as you know kind
of a reporter and a columnist if the
sealons o ball wind up in New York and
see what happens if they try to shove
him into the triangle and you know a
player that has no business whatsoever
it's completely undermining skills by
playing the triangle how does Alonzo
ball factor into that but as far as
negatively affecting his stock there are
so many other variables like shady
characters in their lives you know you
know own lifestyle habits Lonzo balls
lebar ball his father has no impact
whatsoever on his draft stock if the
drac draft was today would it matter who
had the number one pick as to who they
would be taking you know I don't think
so I've done kind of a straw poll on
this and I've heard a few GM say they're
interested to see what josh jackson
looks like in the tournament and if you
absolutely have a point guard that you
can you know build around maybe you lean
toward the Josh Jackson but there is so
much anticipation and so much belief in
what marquel folds can do at Washington
and similarly if Lonzo ball makes a run
to the Final Four he might be able to
leapfrog faults because folks isn't
playing and you might be able to keep
that memory fresh these two guys in
their transcendent types of talents
you'd be hard-pressed to find too many
people in the NBA that don't believe
both these guys are going to turn into
ten-year All Stars All NBA type point
guards both play different ways and but
both these guys have a real chance to be
special the lakers are tanking now
officially yeah and you know what the
NBA if the NBA doesn't come down on them
they should shut up about everything
else about Philadelphia about any of
these other teams that do it the lakers
are brazenly tanking and I know Timothy
Mozgov has been an afterthought for most
of this season but for most of the first
half of the year Luol Deng was a starter
and he averaged about 26 minutes per
game seven and a half points he wasn't a
great player but he was contributing and
these two guys combined make 136 million
dollars in total salary and you're just
going to say you're shutting them down
this is after you basically gave away
Williams for nothing I'm not saying dan
I don't agree with the strategy they
need to keep that top three Vic but this
is a flagship franchise franchise that
by the way two years ago voted against a
robotic for lottery reform so they want
to see this kind of stuff not happen if
the NBA doesn't come down at least have
something to say about them they cannot
say anything about any of these other
teams doing it explain the linkers draft
situation well if they get inside the
top three they keep their pick if it
falls outside the top three it goes to
Philadelphia so enormous motivation for
the Lakers to be god-awful and fall
inside that top three so this is a
Mustang situation right more or less
because I mean you go into next season
and think about it it's ball foltz josh
jackson / jason statham one of those
guys is likely to be a franchise type
player you have them you've got the the
foundation for something you don't and
you are still crossing your fingers and
hoping that Brandon Ingram develops and
you're still crossing your fingers and
hoping that the Pacers may take some
combination of DeAngelo Russell Julius
Randle and future draft picks in
exchange for Paul George is Chris Mannix
John who is the vertical you said last
year you guaranteed it would not happen
Mayweather and McGregor Dana White
thinks it's going to happen that doesn't
mean it will but he does think it is
going to happen you want to change your
opinion on this now I don't because I
feel like everyone is playing Charlie
Brown to their Lucy there and they're
using this platform to promote their
fighters and to promote their own brand
I mean Mayweather said first of all
mayor the city is coming out of
retirement there's no retirement papers
in boxing you don't come out of
retirement or have to announce that he's
on this undefeated tour in Europe who
cares I mean why is he doing an
undefeated to right now he is using this
to build up the TMT brand and make
himself a keep himself relevant in the
sport I check in semi-regularly den with
two sources that would have direct
knowledge of this and neither one of
these sources has told me anything that
makes me think it's at all close right
now these two sides they are so far
apart on what they want and the bottom
line with the stand is that if you make
a deal like this and you have to put up
say
Lee 150 million dollars in guarantees
somebody's going to have to guarantee
that and in the case of mayweather
pacquiao that was one thing we all knew
that fight was going to do an enormous
number when may with a MacGregor if it's
made and I'm still skeptical but if it's
made he is going to be the most negative
there's gonna be so much negative
backlash because this fight is a total
joke you've got may weather the greatest
boxer in the world and McGregor who
doesn't box look it's hyperbole maybe
but I think conor mcgregor's got a
better chance of beating Michael Phelps
in a pool than he does mayweather in a
boxing ring that's how different these
sports are and our little chance like
give conor mcgregor and everybody in the
industry dan is going to agree with me
on this and it's going to make the
negative is to make the PR tour the
publicity tour so negative and so
cartoonish that they will never be able
to recoup that money they put up skip
bayless just said that's a hot take
right there well done hey well designed
dance well well well for you yeah well
done if this fight does happen you have
to come in and spin the wheel of
punishment i think that's oh no no no no
i'm not on your staff their den that's
that's not I'm not I'm not playing that
game i'm not i see your wheel of
punishment I don't I'm not shaving my
head or my eyebrow or okay I know what
is how about this a pie to the face I
take a part of the thing all right fair
enough and apparently not from
Christie's wife but I'll take a bite of
the fan you have and you have to break
up with Ricky Rubio no I mean I'm glad
you brought him up well if I didn't you
were going to oh oh I've got oh yeah
I've got his numbers right in front of
me the month of March he's shooting
forty-three percent from three look at
that number dan we need to start
rethinking the MVP conversation
minnesota Elijah Minnesota if I say in
the stand yeah it's about time by the
way why do they keep trading this guy
who is so good and improved so much he
was going to get traded a couple of
times this year whoa whoa whoa whoa
going to get traded and get a trader and
an open thing they couldn't find anybody
who wanted a little guy he is going to
become as iconic the world as Kevin
Garnett was MVP hallmark Michaelson
hallmark has to create some cards with
you and Rubio
it just you in Rubio in mind that that
you can send to him every month you know
when you see his Purefoy he has played
well I give you credit these fees played
well and has 17 points 12 assists
hundred forty-three percent from the
floor month of them while this team is
rising in the Western Conference
standings dig into the playoffs top five
MVP would you take him over Russell
Westbrook or James Harden right now no
okay good that was painful yeah that was
real painful all right Chris we look
forward to smashing you in the face with
a pie all right Dan all right that's
chris mannix yahoo is the vertical so
conor mcgregor is a better chance of
beating michael phelps in a swimming
content than he would Floyd Mayweather
i'm going to say has a better chance
with Floyd Mayweather he does Michael
Phelps I don't know if we're conor
mcgregor can swim but it just feels like
there's so much money involved in this
what do you like it or not you know like
it just feels like it's going to happen
because there's so much money attached
to this the Dan Patrick show weekday
morning on audience